it's a new report from the World Health
Organization is warning people not to
eat processed meat saying it can cause
cancer bloomberg's john tozzi has been
covering this story one of the most read
right now on the Bloomberg terminal for
good reason right a lot of us are red
meat eater so John what exactly is the
wh 0 saying sure well and to be clear
the wh 0 did not say that people should
not eat red meat or process me what
they're saying is they looked at the
evidence of whether these meats can
cause cancer in humans and after
evaluating all the evidence that
gathered global scientists experts in
their field from across the globe and
they came to a determination that said
processed meat is a carcinogen it has
the it does elevate your risk of certain
types of cancer and red meat they judged
a probable carcinogen okay so red meat a
probable process me a definite
carcinogen so process me being bacon ham
right what I heard meat sausages um you
know span canned meats you know anything
that's sort of shelf stable um you know
that sort of thing um and is it as bad
as like smoking cigarettes or drinking
alcohol well no so the processed meat is
not as dangerous as smoking at
cigarettes that's not what the wh 0 is
saying what they're saying is it's in
the same category of hazzard which is
sort of saying how well do we know
whether or not this substance is a
carcinogen and they're saying we have
the same certainty now about processed
meats as we do about tobacco that
doesn't mean consuming those two
products has the same risk I think it's
pretty clear that tobacco has a higher
risk right my understanding but so but
there is an elevated risk even if it's
smaller than you know other things that
we have heard about as carcinogens so
the North American Meat Institute one of
many of the meat lobby has called this
report a dramatic and alarmist overreach
it defies both common sense and numerous
studies showing no correlation between
meat and cans
they're what research are they selling
well so the meat industry is
understandably pushing back against this
result but it's important to understand
that the wh 0 finding isn't based off
one study it's based on the accumulated
scientific evidence on how risky these
substances are this is a process they've
done for hundreds of chemicals and other
even things like careers occupational
exposures for people like hairdressers
or painters are at greater risk of
developing cancer so um you know there
are studies that haven't shown
correlations but when they look at the
accumulated evidence the judgement of
these experts who are vetted for
conflicts of interest their supposed
non-biased independent scientific
experts there this is their conclusion
and do they say what kind of cancer is
processed because the primary risk here
that they're looking at is colorectal
cancer also known as bowel cancer in the
u.s. it's the second leading cause of
cancer death that's about 50,000
mortality in the u.s. each year
according to the CDC so there are some
other types of cancer that are being
looked at in terms of stomach cancer
pancreatic cancer other sites but
primarily bowel cancer